senator Elizabeth Warren isn't actually
an American Indian obviously but that
didn't slow her down or stop her from
submitting some recipes to an American
Indian cookbook called powwow Chow for
real
several the recipes seem to have been
plagiarized too but why get hung up on
that let's get back to the core question
how do Elizabeth Warren's Indian recipes
stack up as food we got to copy the book
we decided to investigate with
professional chef and cookbook author
mark Bailey mark Bailey thanks for
joining us thank you for having a lot of
controversy around Elizabeth Warren's
Native American heritage yes you know
and a lot of people kind of waited on it
we thought we would approach it
empirically and reverse-engineer one of
the recipes that she contributed to a
1984 book called powwow chat were
prominent Native Americans construed
recipes from their tribe you see her
here asking how and we're gonna discover
how this dish is made we're try of
course the Cherokee is a traditional
dish yes I'm not try what is it the cold
omelet with crabmeat does you know my
breakfast guru in it has never ever
heard of this so I'm very excited and
it's a cold omelet for the first time
something like a with crab meat yeah
with crab meat the crab meat is actually
used as a dressing which is interesting
so you the the omelet is flat as a
pancake which is you know normally a it
has a little bit more girth to it but
this is flat as a pancake her particular
recipe added some tomatoes tarragon and
some cream to the to the egg mix now I
don't want to begin under skeptic but
crab me you don't think of the Cherokee
is a seafaring tribe yes so that's
interesting a little twist that a little
okay how is this done you know what so
again we did a flat flat omelet
we added tomatoes tarragon as well as
parsley and some cream to the egg
mixture okay just put a little on the
light on the bottom of the pan really
really lightly flip it one time and then
you make a crab dressing it's almost
like a mayonnaise dressing that I have
right you know in a in a strip yeah you
basically use lump crab you have you
know oil you're basically making the the
the mayonnaise from scratch so you can
egg mustard everything in there as well
some I haven't you basically create this
dressing which is so interesting and you
just top it right on top of the omelet
and
old notion do you think this is and I
know you're not a cultural
anthropologist yes this seems something
that's within the reach of a hunter
gathering tribe I you know what I
probably wouldn't say the saucepans the
whole lump crab the main right I don't
know if it was maybe inspired by certain
things but I'm not sure because I mean
obviously if you know if you think about
Native Americans in terms of what they
would be cooking with and eating with
this not necessary there's not one comes
right to my as a professional chef and I
don't want you to weigh in on this
kosher is you're a professional we don't
want to sully that but when you were
cooking this huh did what culture came
first to mind was it the traditional
Native American culture the culture of
Elizabeth Warren or or another you know
what it's so funny because with the crab
meat and the fact that it's cold it gave
me European and then Ischl II when I was
making it and then you know me once
again being a breakfast guru you know
the omelet just basically rings American
to me all America and breakfast food you
know exactly so what it can we taste it
sure sure definitely and I just want to
know look this is not a DNA testing
which is again but it's redolent of
Native American culture I'm about to
tell you and I share this yes yes yeah
everything is good to go yes definitely
you know you let me know I mean I don't
you know I don't dabble too much with
Native American cooking but I wouldn't
this is not what would come to mind
immediately but again I'm not an expert
but it's good this is traditional
Cherokee food sign me I can see why
Elizabeth Warren would pretend to be a
member of contributed to powwow Chow
uh-huh you've got a book yes not Native
American no its breakfast in bed I'm
actually cooking in boxers I'm fully
dressed today guys it's cold okay what
cooking involves at 50 ways to keep your
mate in bed yes so you're made in bed
exactly if someone asks you to
contribute to powwow Chow like maybe a
second edition would you feel
comfortable doing that sure I'll do a
little research though it has been
alleged that this is a plagiarized
recipe from a French chef would that see
you know what with recipes sometimes
you're you know you're you're faced with
the recipe and then you want to put your
own twist on it right you know so you
want to be inspired so I'm not sure if
that was your cultural identity is like
that thank you very much